more women coming forward to say Nathan
chasing horse sexually assaulted them
thank you for joining us at four I'm
Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus the 8
news now investigators have been
uncovering more about the Dances with
Wolves actor at the center of multiple
investigations Vanessa Murphy speaking
with both police and potential victims
she joins us in studio Vanessa yeah a
warrant for sexual assault is issued for
Nathan chasing horse in Canada and more
charges are likely on the way from
another Police Department there as we
reported his arrest here is likely just
the tip of the iceberg numerous sources
telling me the alleged cult leader
victimized indigenous women and children
in different locations for decades we've
learned at least one woman came forward
in British Columbia the alleged abuse
happening multiple times and ending in
2018 and zucina Nation police in Canada
announcing charges are likely to come
from their investigations sources tell
me me they believed there were missed
opportunities to investigate chasing
horse and victims felt they were ignored
I asked about this
ignored on any sexual assault
investigation
um
that you need to come forward and we are
committed to make sure that your voice
is heard
we don't want our victims to be further
victimized by being ignored at this
point both local police and the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police are
investigating chasing horse you can
think of that as the Canadian version of
the FBI now the FBI here not confirming
this just yet but I have learned through
my research the FBI is investigating
chasing horse some sources telling me
it's about time Brian back to you